[Music]
okay let's get started
it's looking a man I need a man huh I
apply errs the lesbian solution oh okay
let's get started
[Music]
I love my king this is not really the
most feminine moment for me not really
my 2020 vibe but it does proportion eyes
my giant man hands right no one thinks
I'm cute let's get started okay look
this video is about canceling also known
as cancel culture formerly known as
called out culture and I knew kids know
all about this but before we dive in I
have to explain the basics to my fellow
boomers so listen up oldies in the lingo
of these young half ekkada guzzling
smartphone addicts who killed appellees
canceling is online shaming vilified and
ostracizing but prominent members of a
community by other members of that
community like so much internet slang
this use of the word canceling started
out on black twitter where a few years
ago people well
mostly women would tweet canceled or
kelly and things like that you know it
started out as a vigilante strategy for
bringing justice and accountability to
powerful people who previously had been
immune to any consequences for their
actions
for example the me2 movement promised to
use social media shaming to topple
sexually abusive men in power who
couldn't be held accountable any other
way the promise of canceling was that it
was going to give power back to people
who had none and bring justice to
prominent abusers it's in a way the 21st
century version of the iya teen the
bringer of Justice the people's Avenger
but also like the guillotine it can
become a sadistic entertainment
spectacle and I want to make the case
that we do have well a teensy bit of a
reign of terror situation on our hands
Gorge now there's a version of this
conversation that's already been had to
death and it goes like this on the one
side are a bunch of male comedians who
constantly [ __ ] about how canceled
culture is out of control you can't joke
about anything anymore without these
millennial jackals trying to get you in
trouble and the other side is mostly
progressive think piece authors who
argue that there's no such thing as
canceled culture it's just that powerful
people are finally being held
accountable for their actions and they
can't [ __ ] handle it so they go
around bitching about canceled culture
now unfortunately neither those
viewpoints is quite as correct as some
people might hope
so it's a good thing I'm here to deliver
through the truth you didn't know I was
transgender
story time emotional not clickbait let's
start with an example the most high
profile YouTube canceling of 2019 was
the canceling of James Charles and again
I know you kids remember this but I have
to reheat ancient YouTube tea for the
elders put the kettle on Karen so James
Charles is a twenty year old beauty guru
which means them boomers look there's
these people who make youtube videos
teaching you how to do makeup it's worth
checking out if you can figure out how
to start up internet explorer I
certainly can't it's pretty bomb it's
lit it's uh it's groovy it's fab it's
far out man it's a gas I fully ticket
free love give peace a chance Nixon's a
fascist
so back in May of this year James's
colleague and mother figure fellow
YouTube beauty guru Tati Westbrook
uploaded a 40 minute video accusing
James of endorsing a different brand of
hair vitamins van the brand thought she
lee that was a competitor of her brand
of hair vitamins an enthralling plotline
I know and this was huge this was
covered in the New York Times and while
taki was added oh it doesn't
afterthought to the hair vitamin dispute
she also accused James of being a
predator
now I actually went back and checked
toddies original deleted video and she
actually never uses the phrase sexual
predator it's funny I remember her
calling him that because that became the
story on Twitter but what she actually
said was James had to try to trick
straight men into thinking they're gay
oh my god you tried to trick a straight
man into thinking he's gay
yet again which is
pretty different from calling him a
sexual predator
but see this is what cancel culture does
it takes one story and transforms it
into a significantly different story
you know the headline I would write
about the James and Tati story might
read Tati Westbrook accuses James
Charles of trying to trick straight men
into thinking they're gay but canceled
culture transforms that story into the
headline James Charles is a sexual
predator interesting now I wanna make it
clear that my intention here is really
not to defend James Charles I'm not a
Jameis Charles Stan I have a biological
female in my 30s close to death I know
please leave a comment before I die that
said I do think this statement
James Charles is a sexual predator is a
stretch to say the least
at least based on the information I have
in December 2019 so let's analyze how
this kind of truth stretching happens
cancel culture trope one and you should
be writing this down a class because
this will be on the test
cancel culture trope one presumption of
guilt there's a traditional
understanding of justice according to
which before you condemn or punish a
person you hear the accusers side of the
story and the accused side of the story
you allow both sides to present evidence
and only after everyone involved has had
a chance to make their case do you pass
sentence and to punish the convict Oh
won't punish me King dragging this is
punishment enough of my own Council dad
please now in the United States of we
legally have the presumption of
innocence but canceling does not abide
by the law canceling is a form of
vigilante mob justice and a lot of times
an accusation is proof enough now that's
basically the point of the progressive
slogan believe victims it's a norm that
was put into place and progressive
spaces
because out in the world at large people
generally don't believe victims but I
think it's pretty obvious how believe
victims is a norm that's easy to abuse
was taught eerily James's victim no
she's not some powerless woman abused by
a prominent man in her industry she's on
top of the industry and she wasn't
victimized by James at all I see this
case more as she weaponized canceled
culture against a business rival enemy
before James had even had a chance to
respond to Tottie's accusation the story
had already gone from Totti Westbrook
accuses James Charles of trying to trick
straight men to James Charles tried to
trick straight men and from there it was
generalized into James Charles is toxic
and manipulative which brings us to
canceled culture trope to abstraction
abstraction replaces the specific
concrete details of a claim with a more
generic statement in the transition from
Tati Westbrook accused James Charles of
trying to trick straight men to Jameis
Charles is toxic and manipulative we've
lost not only the sense of this being an
unverified accusation but we've also
lost all the specific details Jameis
Charles is toxic and manipulative is an
incredibly vague statement and may as
well be James Charles is bad but even
without the presumption of guilt if
someone tells me Jameis Charles is
accused of toxic and manipulative
behavior I'm gonna think oh that sounds
pretty bad and I'm gonna start
speculating about the specifics and
whatever my imagination comes up with is
likely going to be worse than whatever
he's actually accused of also the
specific accusation that he tried to
trick straight men into thinking they're
gay is self-evidently kind of
questionable how do you trick straight
men and to think
they're gay if you find out let me know
it's bad I'm bad I'm super bad this is
our problem that straight men usually
seemed out of at the very least it
requires further explanation it's the
kind of story that sounds like it has
more than one side so I'm immediately
gonna feel a little bit skeptical of the
accusation and I'm also gonna side I
Tatti Westbrook because this accusation
is setting off my homophobia detection
alarm don't leave the gays alone but I'm
not gonna have an opportunity to pick up
on the potential homophobia and be
skeptical of it if all I've heard about
the situation is Jameis Charles's toxic
and manipulative and I also want to
point out a linguistic shift that's
happening here when the claim was James
Charles tried to trick straight men the
verbs in the sentence were try and trick
so what we're criticizing here is
James's behavior we're criticizing
things he did allegedly trying to trick
straight man
but once the claim morphs into James
Charles is toxic and manipulative the
verb in the sentence is is to be so
these adjectives are characteristics of
James and it's now known as actions were
criticizing but his personality his
toxicity his manipulative Ness
this is what I'll call canceled culture
trope three essentialism essentialism is
when we go from criticizing a person's
actions to criticizing the person
themselves we're not just saying they
did bad things we're saying they're a
bad person and that's what takes us from
James charla tried to trick straight man
to James Charles is a sexual predator so
here we're targeting James himself not
just his actions but the type of person
he is a sexual predator and we've also
really escalated the accusation because
I don't know about you guys but when I
hear the phrase sexual predator the
image that comes to mind is a rapist or
a child molester maybe an abusive boss
not a teenage twin come upon wanting to
date straight guys I mean not that a
person like that could
be a sexual predator but I really don't
think that he's a sexual predator is a
fair summary of the accusation so this
seems to me like a pretty nasty and
dishonest twisting of the story and it
happened instantaneously on Twitter it
totally dominated the conversation in a
community of millions of people for
weeks in a few days
James had lost millions of subscribers
and who knows what effect it had on his
personal life not that anyone seems to
care in fact most people seems to be
enjoying his downfall
he was a teenage millionaire a young
beautiful superstar easy to envy easy to
resent hard to relate to hard to
sympathize with what was the point of
canceling James Charles did we want to
teach him a lesson did we want him to
learn from his mistakes and grow as a
person
imagine imagine acting wadding someone
to learn I can imagine actually caring
my hunch is that the average Beauty
viewer was not sincerely outraged and
hurt by their sincere belief that James
Charles was a sexual predator in other
words this was not a case of triggered
sjw's this was a controversy
manufactured from the top by a handful
of seemingly vindictive and envious
people I honestly think that most of the
James Charles is a sexual predator crowd
just wanted to bring him down a peg
cancel culture trope for pseudo moralism
or pseudo intellectualism if you look at
the world we live in would you say that
people are usually motivated by a sense
of moral integrity and intellectual
rigor no maybe not let's be real America
we are a bunch of morally impotent
meatbags constantly [ __ ] ourselves
out of fear and lust for tachi calling
out James this was really it was about
the hair of vitamins right I think this
was super salty that this millionaire
kid who she had supported and helped had
betrayed her by endorsing a rival brand
and accusing him of trying to trick
straight man was just a twist of the
knife but moralism or intellectualism
provide a phony pretext for the call-out
you can pretend you just won an apology
you can pretend you're just a concerned
citizen who wants the person to improve
you can pretend you're simply offering
criticism when what you're really doing
is attacking a person's career and
reputation out of spite envy revenge I
mean it could be any motivation Twitter
feud James as an over privilege spoiled
little broth and it was fun to wipe the
smile off his smug face at least for a
few weeks
its schadenfreude awright this is kind
of petty sadism
maybe not the internet's proudest moment
but not the most shameful either and
that's not to say that everyone
canceling James Charles was insincere
but there's a world of difference
between cancelar Kelly and canceled
James Charles and I'm interested to know
how these two things came to look the
same when James was being canceled
I remember being kind of transfixed by
the sight of his life and career falling
from the sky full tailspin black smoke
spewing out and a lot of my YouTube
friends were like well did you see James
Charles's canceled ello ello ello lol
but I looked up at James and I said oh
god that's gonna be me someday stay
strong sister don't let the bastards get
you down
[Music]
let's switch over to white claw these
are cute these are fun a little more of
a feminine moment for me they didn't
even have these last time I was an
alcoholic not even wearing makeup
I don't need make-up to serve a full
biological fantasy keep drinking people
we're gonna make it through this
together so I was doing a little Twitter
archeology when I was looking into the
James Charles cancelling and I found a
bunch of tweets referencing earlier
James Charles scandals you all forgiving
James Charles he's still a trans phone
y'all are acting like just because James
Charles has receipts he's no longer a
racist trans folk like James Charles his
racist ablest transphobic and a sexual
predator all white woman you are me to a
harsh on him and he's uncounseled so
according to Twitter James Charles is
not only a sexual predator he's also a
racist and a trans hope that sounds
pretty serious let's investigate we'll
start with the transphobia allocation
catgirls of the jury exhibit so you're
not even full gay I mean know there have
been girls in the past that I thought
were really really beautiful there's
also been like trans guys in the pasta
too that I would like really early into
for a moment in time and I hope as I say
on Twitter yikes the same itchy friendly
reminder that this isn't a good look
maybe don't be transphobic disappointing
so James did [ __ ] up here the problem is
he's suggesting that being attracted to
trans men makes him less gay which
implies that trans men aren't really men
which is at odds with the way trans men
understand themselves so this does is
our criticism no doubt no doubt
however what I see when I look at this
clip of James is not a dyed-in-the-wool
transphobic bigot I see a very young
person who's still working on
understanding his own sexuality and is
trying to figure out where his
attraction to trans men fits into that
and it seems to me that the
proportionate response to that situation
is for someone to take James aside and
explain to him look here's why what you
said is hurtful to transmit
and here are some tips on how to avoid
saying that kind of thing in the future
you know ignorance is not the same thing
as hatred not understanding someone is
not the same as wanting them dead of
course there are committed bigots who is
just a waste of time to engage with but
sometimes just talking to someone with a
little patience and understanding is all
it takes but that's not what cancel
culture does oh no we have to
immediately escalate every situation to
the highest possible level of conflicts
so by abstraction we get Jameis Charles
may transfer the comments and by
essentialism we get Jameis Charles is a
trans folk we don't give him a chance to
reflect we don't give him an opportunity
to learn we go straight to branding him
a bigot nonetheless that same week James
posted an apology to his Ennis to story
saying regardless of whatever my
intentions were that came across as me
saying I'm not fully gay because I have
been with a trans man and that is
absolutely first of all not true like
that doesn't make me not fully gay but
that stereotype in implication is really
really dangerous and I'm very very sorry
if you are a trans man you are a man if
you're a trans girl you are a woman you
are valid in your identity could you ask
for a better apology like he not only
apologizes for what he said but he also
demonstrates a clear understanding of
why it was wrong so does that mean
people stopped calling him a trans Fobo
of course not canceled culture trope 5
no forgiveness
cancel errs will often dismiss an
apology as insincere no matter how
convincingly written or delivered and of
and insincere apology is further proof
of what a Machiavellian psychopath you
really are now sometimes a good apology
will calm things down for a while but
the next time there's a scandal
the original accusation will be raised
again as if you never apologized and
that's what happened to James during the
toffee scandal when Twitter decided he
was a transphobic sexual predator
and let's just say nothing of this
racism I've been hearing about here the
receipts Exhibit B in February 2017 when
James was much less famous than he is
now he tweeted I can't believe we're
going to Africa today oMG what if we get
Ebola James were fine we could have
gotten it at Chipotle last year okay
well that's a little insensitive maybe
but it's not really something an
influencer should tweet and fear of
disease associated with Africa I mean I
can see how it's in the same big
conceptual area as certain racist tropes
but clearly this was intended as a joke
about his friend mistaking Ebola for
e.coli right and anyway he did apologize
saying as a white sis mail I recognize
my privilege and would never want to
take that for granted but I [ __ ] up
I feel awful for posting what I said I
understand why what I said was offensive
an ignorant and Jameis hasn't made a
habit of making jokes like that ever
since so is this one tweet from two
years ago that he apologized for on its
own enough evidence for us to justify
labeling him a racist
well according to canceled culture
absolutely abstraction takes us from two
years ago
Jameis Charles made a joke that
referenced his fear of getting Ebola in
Africa too James Charles made a racist
joke and then essentialism takes us to
James Charles is a racist
[Music]
look I want to pause to say I really do
believe in social justice at least as
much as trash like me believes than
anything and believe me I am well aware
that jokes irony and even complaints
about canceled culture are often used by
bigots to cloak their real agenda the
Southern Poverty Law Center even cited
my video about how far-right racists use
jokes and memes and mockery of sjw's as
a way to camouflage their hateful
beliefs and make them more palatable to
a wider audience so I'm coming at this
from a place of a genuine concern for
anti racism and anti transphobia as well
as an awareness of the fact that
canceled culture is often just a
conservative red herring used to shut
down any and all complaints about racism
or transphobia but I've also become very
disillusioned with the way these
accusations are thrown around so
frivolously on social media by the way
they're used to escalate conflict
instead of promote understanding and by
the way they're sometimes a weaponized
to destroy people who have made mistakes
but who really don't deserve to be
destroyed now maybe you're thinking
destroyed what do you mean destroyed
James is a 20 year old millionaire on
his way to owning his own makeup Empire
and you are completely correct if you're
James Charles if you're a superstar then
being cancelled most likely does not
destroy you
the cancel errs blend into the general
backdrop of haters and they can set you
back a few million subscribers and a lot
of emotional turmoil but in the long run
they can't really touch your success but
here's the thing what if you're not
James Charles what if you're a small
creator what if you can't afford to
publicly
so what if you belong to a marginalized
community and you rely on that community
for support well in that case it's a
whole different story
let's Irish up this coffee shaken not
stirred it spilled over my [ __ ] oh
that's good
booze and coffee is a good combination
I'm feeling amped right now I'm feeling
a height so this is the part in the
video where I should admit that I'm not
just a casual observer here at the time
I'm making this video sweaty I'm super
Hansel you know I try to make videos
that are both informative and
entertaining so in this video the
information is you get to learn about
canceled culture and the entertainment
is you get to watch a worm try to
wriggle off a hook let's get started
forgive me Father for I have sent a how
are you god I never wanted to be the
kind of youtuber who would resort to
making videos about my own drama but
things have gotten to a point I feel
like I cannot continue this channel
until he's built some teeth so let's get
started okay first a little backstory a
little me is awesome I've never talked
about this on my channel before so this
is a super [ __ ] vulnerable moment for
me but I am in fact a transgender woman
which may come as a big shock to many of
you since I'm 100% real fish I get
comments all the time from like very
solemn people like guys I'm pretty sure
this is a dude great work detective
you're cracked the case you're doing
very good sweetie very very good
I guess one of YouTube's leading a
b-list transgendered I have a prime
target for cancellation and I have been
cancelled many many times and we're
going to talk about some of the things
I've been canceled for and some of the
things I've been criticized for and the
difference between criticism and
cancelling because yes there is a
difference as we go along
I will admit where I have made mistakes
because despite how I look I am NOT a
literal goddess and I will heed I will
apologize where I believe apologies are
due however where I believe that
criticism of me is excessive or
unwarranted I will not apologize because
here I Contra points industries we are
not in the business of serving [ __ ]
so the reason for my current
cancellation is
in summary that in my last video
opulence I cast transsexual porn star
buck angel in the role of John Waters
and yes it's a much better story than
the hair vitamin D buckle so notify the
drama channels put in a good word for me
because sweetie I'm not here to make
friends I'm here to win so basically I'm
cancelled for collaborating with buck
angel and a lot of trans people think
buck angel is a horrible person and so
my collaboration with buck angel is
evidence that I too am a horrible person
cancel culture trope 6 the transitive
property of cancellation cancellation is
infectious if you associate with a
cancelled person the cancellation rubs
off
it's like gonorrhea except doxycycline
won't save you this time sweetie look
this whole incident hinges first of all
on whether buck angel is in fact a
horrible person so who is buck angel
well he's a trans man of my parents
generation he grew up in a world where
there was not anything like the
visibility and access to information
about transition we have today and where
there was a strict medical gatekeeping
system in place for people who wanted to
transition in fact buck was the first
female to male patient his doctor had
ever treated in the 2000s he rose to
prominence as an adult performer his
gimmick at the time being the man with a
[ __ ] but he also became an activist he
wanted to create more positive trans
representation within the porn world and
from there he'd become a more general
educator and advocate for trans people I
first heard about him in the early
2010's when I was doing some googling
about some little gender issues I was
having myself though I ended up deciding
to remain a female and buck was one of
the first female-to-male people I'd ever
heard about and he made an impact on me
in parks you take one look at him and
you think honey that's a man but he was
born a woman
I can do that so it's not that he
inspired me to transition or anything
it's just it was one of many moments
along my whole entire gender journey so
I had positive feelings about trampa
that's three calls himself from back
then and then a few months ago when I
was feeling angry and miserable and
despised over another time I was being
canceled by trans Twitter we'll get to
that one later I saw this post from buck
on Instagram dear beautiful human being
I see your pain it is okay that you lash
out at me you do this because I am you
and you are reflecting yourself hate to
me I am strong and will be here for you
forever and no matter what this is my
intention as a human being to help
others love buck angel and the caption
suffering that is why the trans
community lashes out at each other I am
very aware of the hate towards me by
some in the community they hate on me
and others because they are hurt and
those were exactly the words I needed to
hear at that moment so I commented a
heart and then buck to young to me and
he said I love you and I was like senpai
noticed me and so I said I love you back
then when I was working on opulence I
needed a voice actor to do a line from
John Waters book and it was my
co-director Theron who suggested don't
you think buck angel sounds kind of like
John Waters and I said well he just
messaged me on insta let's see if he
wants to do it and I just loved the idea
of having [ __ ] angel as John Waters in
the video credits like a trans icon
playing a gay icon in my head it was
just so well iconic so he got in touch
with buck about the line and he was like
yeah I'd love to do it so here it is the
10-second voice-over clip that ruined a
month of my life one must remember there
is such a thing as good bad taste and
bad bad taste to understand bad taste
one must have very good taste that's it
children
that's why mommies cancelled now I was
aware at the time that trans Twitter
hated buck angel but my thinking was
well trans Twitter kind of hates every
trans celebrity and they certainly hate
me so I wasn't gonna let that stop me
little did I know quite how vicious
things were about to get now so far I've
been telling this story from my point of
view but I do want to give a fair and
balanced account so I want to pause and
contextualize boys some trans people
hate buck angels so much they're willing
to cancel anyone who even associate
with him basically it all goes back to
this old debate in the trans community
known today and tumblr lingo as true
scum versus transgenders so true scum
are trans people who distinguish between
true trans people and fake trans people
who they call trenders or to cutes
usually true scum think that what it is
to be trans is to have a lifelong
struggle with dysphoria to pursue a
medical transition involving hormones
and surgery and to socially reassimilate
into your target binary gender so male
or female anyone who is not that
according to true scum must either be a
confused teenager
someone just trying to get attention
someone mistaking their trauma or their
fetish for being trans in a word at
render so that's a vigil transness that
usually excludes non-binary people as
well as people who don't want to
medically transition for whatever reason
and for that reason this view is
sometimes also called trans medical ism
true scum obviously being the derogatory
term for these people so true scum are
very hated by a lot of trans people
because their viewpoint is that not all
trans identities are valid and buck
angel is widely perceived to be true
scum so the next question to ask is is
this true
is buck angel in fact truths come now my
honest answer to that question is I
don't know he certainly said some things
that sound like things fruits come say
I'll give you that the point he likes to
make a lot is that he's transsexual not
transgender and the difference between
those terms is sometimes defined as
transsexual imply that you want to
pursue medical transition so hormones
and surgery and transgender doesn't
imply that and people associate this I'm
transsexual not transgender thing with
true scum because true scum often call
themselves transsexuals and say that
anyone who isn't a transsexual
isn't really trans and often those
people will be very mean to people they
call trenders especially certain
transmeta close youtubers like Vanessa
LeBlanc and too cute Smasher 9000 turkey
Smasher 9 doesn't roast my back cough
and I dare you but I think it's
important to keep in mind that the term
true scum is a product of the 2014
tumbler Wars and trying to apply it to
trans people of an older generation can
sometimes be misleading like when buck
angel transitioned the word transsexual
was just the
word for his identity and he still
identifies that way so when younger
trance he will tell him it's wrong teens
the word transsexual he feels like these
ungrateful Millennials are invalidating
his identity and I do understand where
he's coming from with that but I also
understand why a lot of non-binary
people are skeptical about buck like he
says again and again I'm transsexual not
transgender like don't mix me up with
those people and that eagerness to
separate himself from transgender people
it comes across as hostility like I
don't think he's ever actually said that
non-binary people aren't valid but I
personally don't like that he seems like
he wants to distance himself from them
and that's my desert Grimaud with buck
it's not that he invalidates non-binary
identities because I don't really see
him doing that and if he was doing that
I would have seen it because for the
last two months a lot of people have
been doing nothing but sending me
problematic buck angel tweets but as
someone who cares a lot about non-binary
people and who loves the non-binary
people in my life it does upset me when
he does this distancing thing and I hope
he listens to this criticism because I
think it would be cool if he got better
about this of course
buck is technically right that there are
different kinds of trans people and I
agree it's important that we can make
those distinctions and talk about the
differences when they're relevant but I
also think that as a community trans
people benefit from unity not division
like if you have an employer who
discriminates against trans people
they're not gonna care if you're
transsexual transgender non-binary or
gender non-conforming they're gonna
discriminate against you regardless so
we're all in this together and there's a
lot of disagreements among us and we
often don't get along so well but
politically I think we should work
together as much as possible instead of
splitting into little factions because
we share most of the same interests and
I think the best way to do that is to
build bridges instead of burning them
and that's why I'm willing to work with
people like buck angel who I have some
disagreements with it creates a
connection you know and having that
connection can lead to communication and
build understanding also I need all the
connections I can get Gorge
I am very lonely
it's not a joke it's true now I get that
some people have views that are so
harmful that giving them a platform is
potentially dangerous but in any case I
didn't even give puck a platform to
share his opinions I gave him a platform
to be a John Waters impersonator a bunch
of people on my subreddit were like why
couldn't she just get John Waters to do
those lions well first of all I don't
actually know John but I just have a
feeling he would write me off as some
kind of trap millennial sjw like why is
buck angel cancelled but John Waters
isn't well because trans Twitter does
not know who John Waters is and let's
try to keep it that way I actually
mentioned this to a friend of mine who
knows John and he told me that he and
John have actually watched buck angels
porn together so plot twist
okay so trash Twitter won't forgive me
unless I condemn buck angel as true scum
and apologize for ever working with him
but I'm not going to do that because I
don't think it would be the right thing
to do
and doing it just to get my cellphone
cancelled would be cowardly I'm happy to
tell you I absolutely disagree with
Buck's divisive rhetoric about
transsexual versus transgender I wish
you would be an ally to the whole
transgender umbrella instead of trying
to distance himself from the rest and
I'm happy to hear at the perspective of
non-binary people who don't trust him
because I totally get where they're
coming from and I think that's valid but
I also respect the decades if good
activism buck angel has done for trans
people and I am grateful to him for that
and in light of that I'm willing to give
him the benefit of the doubt about where
his heart is and express my criticism in
a more measured way than just attacking
who he is as a person but Twitter
needs to establish that he's a horrible
person because this is the strategy
they've chosen to establish that I am a
horrible person and if the true scum
allegation isn't strong enough to prove
it oh they have other pieces of evidence
to fall back on to hold up their
conclusion for example here's a tweet
claiming Natalie's trying so [ __ ]
hard to make it sound like the only
thing buck angel ever did was write a
few if he tweets and that's just so
[ __ ] far from the truth dude launched
a targeted tabloid harassment campaign
outing a trans woman against her will
with a specific intent of causing her
physical emotional and professional harm
the shorter way of saying that is that
he wanted to make her suffer and she
very well
could have been killed yikes this a nip
chief friendly reminder that this isn't
a good look maybe don't try to get trans
women killed disappointing
it sounds pretty serious let's
investigate here's what I've managed to
piece together scene 1 the Earth's 2003
Los Angeles with a movie world the porn
world in the BDSM scene come together in
a tale of heartbreak betrayal and
transsexualism la-la-land dramatis
personae buck angel transsexual porn
star Ilsa Strix dominatrix then wife of
buck angel lana wachowski wildly
successful director of the matrix at the
time not yet out as a transgender woman
the synopsis is that Ilsa Strix and buck
angels marriage ended after he also had
an affair with lana wachowski who was
not yet out his trans so buck was
understandably upset about the affair
and in what seems like a petty act of
revenge told a series of magazines that
this celebrity director wachowski was a
crossdresser who had stolen his wife
which I guess was the information he had
at the time so is that outing a trans
woman against her will
well in retrospect it seems like it
though that may not be what he thought
he was doing at the time but to really
get to the bottom of this we have to do
some digging we have to troll through
the dirty details of trans people's
personal histories which I've noticed is
one of the Internet's favorite
activities so I actually went on eBay
and I purchased Rolling Stone issue 9 91
January 2006 and I'm finally able to
reveal the seller canceled the order god
dammit
but I was finally able to track down and
translate a Spanish version of The
Rolling Stone article from the wayback
machine and I'm finally able to expose
the truth
stop freeze exactly where you are take a
look at yourself and what all of us have
been doing for the last thirty Seconds
who does this behavior remind you of if
your answer is social justice advocates
fighting for trans equality you are
incorrect if your answer is creepy
stalkers who hate trans people
I am very suspicious of anyone who's
online behavior prompts me to dig
through articles full of dead names and
sort of scandals involving trans people
from almost two decades ago this is very
similar to techniques used against trans
people by internet fascists so I'm
pretty suspicious of anyone pushing this
kind of investigation how can you tell
the difference between a trans and our
Co socialists with an anime avatar and a
Nazi pretending to be a trans anti-flu
socialist with an anime avatar
well you can't anonymous is anonymous is
anonymous whether it's on 4chan or
twitter so unless buck angel Ilsa Strix
or lana wachowski gets in touch with me
and lets me know that for some
unimaginable reason they want me to
publicly dig up their 17-year old
divorce drama this is none of my [ __ ]
business
and it's none of yours either so shut up
and go back to Keeley farms where you
belong
[Music]
let's Irish up this tea doesn't work as
well with tea so setting aside any
tabloid drama that may have happened
during the Bush administration I'm
saying this is a contest way and they
deserve it
they [ __ ] deserve the hunting us I'm
spilling whiskey tea all over my goddamn
bathrobe I'm a lady she's a woman
the main argument against me usually
references a collage of Bukka angels
problematic tweets and this is supposed
to be definitive evidence that he is a
horrible person and therefore that I am
a horrible person for collaborating with
him well here's the thing though a
collage of problematic tweets does not
define a person and I'm very used to
being defined that way myself so I know
how unfair I can be before I ever
collaborated with buck angel a lot of
people on Twitter were already calling
me true scum
that's been going on a year and a half
now and any time my name comes up on
Twitter a bunch of people respond to
saying Natalie as true scum
Natalie's a trans medical Estate's
non-binary people and you should really
think what kind of message you're
sending to your trans and non-binary
followers by platforming her and if the
person defends me or argues back in any
way they say I can't believe you're
ignoring the valid concerns of
marginalized people you know they're
weaponizing their marginalised status as
trans people to isolate and attack
another trans person and sometimes this
stuff gets to my head too I start asking
myself wait am i a trans medical estate
but the answer is no I just don't these
things they're saying about me are 100%
not true you know believe marginalized
people is a norm that has encouraged and
leftist spaces for good reason much like
believe victims or believe women and
these norms were established to
counterbalance the mainstream tendency
which is not to listen to marginalize
people or to victims or to women but any
norm can be abused and the blunt fact of
the matter is sometimes marginalized
people are wrong
sometimes people calling themselves
victims are obscuring a more complicated
situation and it's even happened once or
twice that a woman has lied and the
accusation that I'm truest gun is simply
false I mean first of all I don't even
think of my own transgenderism as a
medical disorder much less everyone
else's I have of course collaborated
with dr. Spiegel at all but I will not
have my artistry reduced to mere
medicine second this accusation that I
hate non-binary people is just no no no
my thinking about trans identity has
always been informed by non-binary
people I used to identify it as
non-binary myself before I medically
transitioned and some of the closest
people to me in my life today are
non-binary trans people some of whom are
also transsexuals incidentally it's
complicated I've also made at least five
videos on this channel arguing for the
validity of non-binary gender identities
going back more than three years so
that's five out of around fifty videos
or ten percent of the content I've made
on this channel is about non-binary
identity a few months ago I even made a
30-minute video called trans trenders
which uses character dialogue to show
what I think are the shortcomings of
trans medical ism but there's still
hundreds of people on Twitter saying
that I'm true scum who hates non-binary
people and their main piece of evidence
for that is a collage of my problematic
tweets so let's take a look at that
here's the three tweets that I usually
see scrapbooks together as definitive
proof that I hate non-binary people this
is the first one from September 2018
notice how it's taken out of context
from the thread so you can't even see
what I'm talking about I'm sure this is
not the experience of many n B's and B
means non-binary people I leave it to
them to articulate what MB existence
looks like in a binary world I do not
and I cannot speak for them but surely
Annika got I used to write like such a
nerd but surely an account that begins
and ends with I'm not a man because I
don't identify as one is pretty weak
okay when I wrote the Twitter thread
that that tweet has been clipped out of
I was defending myself from accusations
that my most recent video at the time
the
aesthetic was anti non-binary in that
video does a character name to Justine
who defends a version of the
performativity theory of gender and
basically I made this video to express
some angst I was feeling about the
pressures of transitioning in the public
eye this was a very one year on hormones
moment for me and I've already moved on
in my thinking at that time I was very
um my behavior must be perfectly
feminine at all times or else I'm not
really a woman my self-esteem is totally
based on sleeping with heterosexual men
who them of my father and anyone who
knows anything about trans women knows
that most of us go through a stage like
this at some point and some youtubers
never get out of it but personally I
mean these days it doesn't matter what I
wear it's when I dream there Lilly's
dreams ha dragging the Danish girl well
[ __ ] the Danish I could never abide that
sort of person we all know what I'm
talking about you can tell them the
whisky is getting to me because I'm
being bigoted against the Danish these
things come out you know you get honest
you get real when you get a little bit
of the Irish in your system did I just
[ __ ] put lipstick outside the [ __ ]
lipliner this is all Billie's fault
Lily Alba [ __ ] her dreams the point is
when I was making the aesthetic I wasn't
even thinking about non-binary people
and people will say that the fact that
not every video I make references
non-binary people is itself and be
phobic as I said about 1 in 10 of my
videos is about non-binary identity but
not all of them are and I feel entitled
to make some videos that are just about
trans women but still some people on
Twitter were saying that the character
Justine is a trans medical esteem a B
wins the fictional debate in the video I
Natalie win am therefore a trans medical
Asteria chiva t theory of gender the one
that Justine defends in that video is
conceptually as far away from trans
medical ism as it is possible to be
trans medical ISM says that trans
identity is biological it's neurological
its hormonal its diagnosable and
treatable
whereas performativity says that
gender is gesture its expression its
performance it's a social phenomenon
phenomenon phenomenon phenomena mannan
phenomenon performativity it makes no
reference to gender dysphoria or to any
kind of medical concept at all
so whereas trans medical ism is a kind
of bio essentialism performativity is a
kind of social constructionism so these
are exact opposite theories of gender
are you following along class I'm not
ready to drink jameson and tea until i
died but some trans people felt
invalidated by things justine says in
that video and trans medical ism is
another thing that makes them feel
invalidated so they decided that justine
is a trans medical list and therefore
that i am a trans medical list and this
is literally just bad a media
comprehension like it's a failure to
plausibly interpret a video that some
people did find genuinely emotionally
difficult and so to the negative
response to that video is just pure
emotion I always hear I don't care what
you intended trans people were hurt by
that video you hurt trans people but
here's the thing just because you were
hurt by content I made doesn't mean that
the content is bad or that I'm
victimizing you in some way I'll give an
example I did a stream a couple years
ago with a BDSM and kink activist we
were talking about various kinks and we
got to DDL G which is Daddy dawn little
girl basically when consenting adults
roleplay age difference in the power
dynamic that comes with that and me and
this kink activists who are just
casually discussing what DD LG is what
it isn't when I noticed someone in the
chat was starting to totally freak out
they were typing in all caps like my
abuser used DD LG to justify raping me
why are you defending my abuser I can't
believe you'd betray me like this please
stop taking my abusers side please stop
I'm begging you this was actually really
[ __ ] upsetting to me because this
person was clearly in a lot of pain they
were having a panic attack because they
were having a trauma trigger reaction to
this conversation
and I kept telling them to leave the
stream and take care of themselves but
they wouldn't do it so I had to block
and then later get in touch and make
sure they were okay now was there pain
very real yes
was it triggered by the content I was
streaming yes but does that mean I did
anything wrong
no is it wrong to talk about kink and
contacts where it's clear you're going
to be talking about kink no but when you
produce content online that's going to
be viewed by thousands or millions of
people there's always some people out
there who are going to be hurt by it so
if you want to argue that a tweet or a
video I made is somehow immoral I think
you need more of an argument than just
people were hurt all right back to the
tweet to this day people quote tweet the
sentence but surely an account that
begins and ends with I'm not a man
because I don't identify as one is
pretty weak and they claimed this as
evidence that I'm true scum or that I
think people have to prove their
identities somehow which is not at all
what I was saying in that thread when I
was saying is if you're trying to
persuade a skeptic that trans identity
is valid simply saying I'm not a man
because I don't identify as one isn't a
very good argument which it isn't I mean
no one has ever been persuaded by that
so far as I'm aware that said I do now
disagree with the mindset I had when I
tweeted this back fan I still
delusionally believed that it was
possible to rationally explain why trans
identity is valid and I was simply
looking for a more persuasive argument
then this is how I identify you have to
believe me no further questions but I no
longer believe there can be any rational
justification of gender identity which
is another reason I'm not a trans matica
list trans medical ism tries to be a
rational theory about why trans identity
is valid and I don't think it succeeds
as that I don't think anything does my
current opinion about this is that I'm
not a man because I don't identify as
one is as good or rather as bad an
argument as any you know some things in
life just can't be rationally explained
like love why do you love the person you
love well because you love them you
could write a poem about it or some gay
[ __ ] like that but you can't give any
actual arguments and to why am i a woman
because in the life that's it I mean I
can describe my experiences and my
feelings to you to help you understand
better but I can't logically prove
anything and I'm super [ __ ] sorry if
you can't handle that mankind was set
adrift in an absurd world that must be
super [ __ ] hard for you tell me all
about it next please
okay again we're mid thread with missing
context but the tweet says whereas I've
met 20 year olds and full-on boy mode
who are like hi I'm a trans woman she
heard pronouns so I guess by including
this tweet in the contra points is
problematic collage people are implying
that I don't think it's valid for
someone who presents male to identify as
a woman and requests she/her pronouns
well that's not true I was surprised
when I first experienced this but I
think it's valid next okay mid thread no
context once again but now you go into
these leftist discord / Facebook groups
and like 20 to 30 percent identify as
some flavor of trans most of them are
not conventional binary transsexuals
that seems to be the future okay well
it's true that many left his discord
servers are like this but reading this
back I don't like the way the phrase
conventional binary transsexuals is
hitting my ear I can see how it could
imply that non-binary identities are
somehow newfangled which isn't true
there's been non-binary people for
longer than there's been medical
transsexuals in fact so we'll call this
a bad tweet I apologize for tweeting it
and I apologize to any non-binary people
who felt trivialized by it okay this is
the big one this tweet got its own
article in the [ __ ] Guardian you know
I really wish people would pay less
attention to the tweets I spend 30
seconds rating and a little more
attention to the videos that I spend you
know hundreds of hours making anyway
let's look at the tweet this is the most
scrutinized paragraph I've ever written
and it's so mediocre this has happened
to me before in hyper woke spaces like
it's me and a bunch of sis women and we
all have to go in a circle saying she
her because I'm there there's this
paradox where I can go to a sports bar
in North Carolina and be miss ma'am doll
night no question but in
self-consciously trans inclusive spaces
I have to explain my pronouns
and watch woke people up wordly corrects
themselves every time they say you guys
I guess it's good for people who use
they/them only and want only
gender-neutral language but it comes at
the minor expense of semi possible
trances like me and that's super [ __ ]
hard for us so people interpreted this
tweet as me being against the practice
of sharing pronouns which I'm literally
just not like I've actually been the
person who initiates the pronoun circle
many times the backstory of this tweet
is basically that I once got triggered
in a situation where I was with a bunch
of sis women and we all had to go around
saying our pronouns and like a typical
triggered truck I tiptoed over to
Twitter that tip top type it out but
here's the thing but the end of this
thread I had already talked myself away
from the initial frustration I was
expressing if you know my videos in my
voice then you know me saying it comes
at the minor expense of semi possible
trances in a super [ __ ] hard for us
is sarcastic it's a minor expense it's
not actually very hard for us gorge it's
fine the people on Twitter don't watch
my videos and they don't get sarcasm
so people flipped out over this I was
getting dragged and it made the poor
decision to try to solve the tweet
problem with more tweeting which 100% of
the time is like trying to put out a
fire with lighter fluid so me and my
dumb brain did another short thread
trying to clarify what I was saying and
defending my right to talk about my own
experiences that didn't make things any
better so in a state of anger and
frustration I tweeted out yet another
thread and this time I said some truly
stupid things including the now-infamous
line I sometimes feel like the last of
the old-school transsexuals I honestly
don't know what the [ __ ] I was even
trying to say I don't feel like the last
of the old-school transsexuals I don't
even know what that means I guess I
basically meant that offline I don't
have any radical aspirations you know I
want to be inconspicuous
I want to blend in and that's what I
meant by old school you know I want
people to assume my pronouns you know
it's funny because it is very different
from the way I am online where I'm
totally shameless and open I'm like
sexual confession everybody's sexual
confession I have abnormal urges they
know I have abnormal urges now they
already knew that but often I'm an
inconspicuous [ __ ] like a total coward
so this was a rage thread and I
apologize for tweeting it let's go back
to bug angel I'm kind of a conscientious
objector to the practice of condemning
someone based on a collage of their
worst tweets taken out of context but I
definitely do have anxiety about this
like I think I'm doing the right thing
by not condemning buck as true scum and
evil but I mean I could be wrong what if
I am basically sacrificing myself for
the sake of a person who really is as
bad as Twitter says maybe tomorrow he'll
tweet [ __ ] non-binary people and then
I'll have [ __ ] up this whole thing is
incredibly stressful to me but I do
believe that by refusing to participate
in the anti buck angel pile on I am
airing on the morally safer side of
things because even if he is a little
true scummy excommunicating him from the
trans community is still probably not
the best approach to take in my
experience when people accept binary but
not non-binary trans people it usually
takes like a 30 minute conversation to
win them over to some level of
non-binary acceptance it'll give you a
couple examples the first time I was
ever cancelled like totally trashed on
Twitter was back in 2017 when I had not
yet medically transitioned and at the
time I identified as non-binary and
VidCon 2017 I met up with a youtuber
named June who had made some videos
where she basically mocked the idea of
non-binary people and I posted a picture
of the brunch I had with June and some
other people but let's keep them out of
it and people on Twitter totally dragged
me for being a peak liberal boot licker
who's best friends with transphobic
abusers Christ [ __ ] people man so
[ __ ] frustrating and you know I'm not
gonna claim I change June's mind because
I don't know what her thought process
was but I did talk to her about
non-binary identity and she did remove
her anti non-binary videos and I don't
have any regrets about that brunch
example - a couple months later I did a
livestream with a conservative trans
woman youtuber named um what was her
name
Sharon Sharon was it Sharon I guess
she's just not a very memorable person
anyway
she had made some videos saying that
non-binary identities aren't real but I
gave her a chance and she surprised me
by being super compassionate and
thoughtful by the end of that stream she
was pretty much totally accepting of my
identity so again the point is not that
I'm some kind of persuasive genius if I
was a persuasive genius maybe I could
talk myself out of being cancelled the
point is that sometimes people who seem
ignorant or hateful just need to be
given a non-judgmental space to learn
and grow and think and to just condemn
them as hopeless bigots actually
prevents that growth from happening and
Sharon
despite her you know totally forgettable
personality turned out to be an
incredibly open-minded person like later
on she actually made an apology video to
non-binary people and I became good
friends with her and we work together on
most of the videos I've made this year
you know until she ruined my life by
recommending and canceled John Waters
impersonator I guess the moral is never
talk to people you disagree with it will
only lead to pain
[Music]
I do think there's something off with my
hormone Davis like I'm crying three
times a day oh and I can't calm in less
there's vibrators and at least three of
my holes
it happens like once a month there has
to be a full moon I honestly only still
bother because it numbs the pain for a
few moments what I'm trying to say is I
really do believe in conversation which
means a hearing out multiple
perspectives I don't want my audience to
get all their information about trans
people from me and I think it's
important to listen to criticism so I
encourage my audience to go watch some
non-binary youtubers who have criticized
me and criticized buck angel for example
go check out non-binary youtuber look
Sanders video about me and non-binary
youtuber cORFO days video about buck
angel I think YouTube as a platform is
better at producing criticism rather
than canceling and I think that's
because at least in the vlog format
making a video forces you to confront
the fact that you're a human being with
a face and a name who can be held
accountable for the things that you say
but people on Twitter it's a different
story and I think it's time we take a
look at what canceling really is I've
given you enough context now for you to
understand what I'm about to show you
which is what I saw on my timeline every
day for nearly a month all these tweets
are from the aftermath of my uploading
opulence two months ago when the buck
angel scandal first broke and so I'm
gonna hold my hands now because this
gets ugly
[Applause]
hey if any of you still support contra
planes after her bigging up in
collaborating with notable turf favorite
and true scum [ __ ] angel you're no
friend to gender nonconforming
non-passing and non-binary trans people
[ __ ] her and [ __ ] her [ __ ] rift
I am absolutely furious right now weird
how I'm 30 and trans and managed not to
be a true scum
maybe I'm just some kind of anomaly or
maybe contra points is a conniving rat
[ __ ] cop oh who could do with a fully
bound backhand to the mouth since I
matter Twitter jail now I just want to
say [ __ ] contra points we're sick of
ethics stance and all her bread tube
chavez who closed ranks to protect her
after she throws the rest of the trans
community under the bus for profit
Natalie Wynn is a [ __ ] grifter contra
points videos are now just style of her
substance so that explains why she took
to turf ideology so well contra points
working with true scum now definitively
proves that pretty much everyone
defending contra points just hates and
B's and are also true scum legit gonna
start on following peeps that continue
to follow contra points at this point
dunno my wedding of pretty much everyone
I know there are some that were probably
blindsided by this somehow so long as
you know that contra points is true scum
you're safe and cool eat [ __ ] Natalie
for someone who used to identify as
genderqueer we expected more from you
but I guess when your heads this far up
your own ass it's hard to consider
others contra points more like
disappoints oh that's a good one
if you're gonna drag me at least be
funny [ __ ] [ __ ] angel [ __ ] contra boots
[ __ ] any real transsexual
[ __ ] your grift here's what hashtags
contra point stands don't understand if
Natalie refuses to accept that she has
an apology to make and continues
profiting from it it will become our
responsibility to work on deep
platforming earth just like every other
racist sexist bigoted content creator no
one has actually suggested or attempted
to actually cancel her but the longer
this goes on without an apology and
commitment to be better
the stronger the case becomes for
actively working to deport her so in
other words no one has suggested we
cancel her but we should cancel her we
can everyone finally agree the contra
points belongs directly on the side of
garbage can here I am sweetie contra
boys collab
with angel buck angel buck thanks for
letting us all know that you had no idea
who he even was until Twitter notified
you what to be outraged about contra
Boyd's collaborating with angel buck a
trans medical astute rants person to try
and destroy them and supporting him
because he looks and sounds like a
proper man isn't a small itty bitty
tipsy topsy [ __ ] mistake this is a
huge deal contra points could be
literally collaborated with Hitler we
have a Hitler comparison could be
literally collaborating with Hitler
today and you all would be like oh well
she's just a little flawed you know [ __ ]
off
can not only win stop being a coward and
commit to being a trans-med it's really
tiring to watch this happen every week
Natalie went is a spoiled brat who
refuses to take accountability anyone
who supports Natalie wins does not
support non-binary people not only when
is such a terrible person my god every
sis and not non-binary person who
thought Natalie win wasn't trans-med now
owes me and every non-binary person $50
joe biden has a better position on the
validity of non-binary genders and
contra points my opinion is that contra
voice really sucks a lot and I don't
like her I hate contra points so goddamn
much it's unbelievable contra points be
like it's a very good impression of me
you're doing very good sweetie
you're doing a very very good buck angel
is a turf apologizer
boot licker and true scum any
association with him must be seen as
hostile to the trans community as a
whole
that alone denial of non-binary
existence that's the line in the sand
folks where do you stand and here we
[ __ ] are dude [ __ ] [ __ ] angel on
contra please eat my entire ass but what
this is natalie natalie is a trans
medical list this is Natalie's friend
Lindsey Lindsey is a left tuber Natalie
and Lindsey are still friends because
Natalie and I are both cowards
left to Missa Greg Owen they made me the
the shaky issues that arose with one
being in contras new video her video on
turfs make no sense now her video on
trans Trender is making no sense now you
know if your interpretation of why I
cast bug angel
totally contradicts the videos I spent
hundreds of hours making do you think
maybe your interpretation could be wrong
apparently not her apology is completely
Floyd sends a message that she hates
non-binary people
she is reckless with her content
positive set arose from [ __ ] angels
being and contrary video she has four
hundred thousand dollars this month from
patreon four hundred thousand this
number is completely made-up like it is
exponentially wrong $400,000 $400,000 a
month odd take contra points is the
leftist PewDiePie personally I like to
characterize her as the Blair White Wolf
and leftist sheep's clothing reminder
that contra points is a piece of [ __ ]
who still has not apologized her
platforming true scum and is actively
taking their side
anyway if you still support contra
points get the hell away from me peepee
poo-poo i'm contra points and i can't
stop being a trans medical isn't
[ __ ] myself in public huh valid
criticisms of marginalized people [ __ ]
contra point [ __ ] tristan contra points
is a true scum contra which is a true
scum contra points end of the true scum
contra points is a true skog carter
points an so tricky you know when you
repeat the same [ __ ] sentence over
and over and then you don't repeat the
same sentence over and over good arcade
doesn't get more persuasive in fact and
might get less persuasive because true
things usually only had to be said once
if you still support content points
unfollow me immediately and never
interact with me again
in conclusion [ __ ] natalie win and [ __ ]
everything she has to say
[Music]
okay let's get started
so that was just a sample of hundreds
and hundreds of tweets and all of this
let me remind you is over a ten-second
voice-over clip in a 48 minute video
about a completely unrelated topic like
how do you work how do you create when a
decision so trivial can become the main
event for weeks of your life and the
tweets are just the beginning after that
there's the reddit threads and the
YouTube comments in the Facebook
discourse in the medium posts in the
Newsweek article opulence is a video
being theron spent hundreds of hours
carefully piecing together I think it's
my best video if to have the response to
it completely overwhelmed by one minor
and casting decision is heartbreaking
and infuriating to me and it's left me
with much less energy to create new
things but here's the thing people on
Twitter saying mean things about me is
not the worst of it not even close
like I'm a politically opinionated trans
woman who publicly transitioned while
making anti-fascist content on a
notoriously right-wing platform Oh
sweaty I am so used to reading mean
things about myself online most of you
probably can't even begin to imagine how
used to it I am and the way you
psychologically survive in that
situation is you block the people in
platforms who are harassing you and you
pay it no mind but there's some things
you can't block and a big one is you
can't block people from going after your
friends and colleagues and that is
exactly what people did to me at the
height of the buck angel incident
Lindsey Ellis Ally from philosophy tube
and each bomber guy all got inundated
with tweets demanding that they publicly
disowned me a person they've all been
friends with for years or else in
response to demands that she apologized
Lindsey released a statement where she
said I was not involved in opulence my
name was mentioned in it but I did not
participate in the production therefore
with regards to calls for me to
apologize
ask apologize for what there is only one
logical answer apologize for being
friends with Natalie and here's a
response to her statement I don't need
to consider you my [ __ ] friend to
disagree with beliefs you knowingly
solicit or allow on your platform
same with contra it just means you're
willing to allow awful ideas to fester
for the sake of financial gain which is
fine but it makes you a piece of [ __ ]
and here's a comment on each bomber guy
I thought that you were gonna read this
but can you please just tell us your
thoughts on that whole situation so we
could at least know that you were on our
side we don't want to have to cancel all
of y'all and cause bread tube to go into
a schism as a result of this thank you
nice YouTube channel you have fair
friend would be a shame of someone
canceled it
so [ __ ] Finister ally of philosophy
tube released his own statement
affirming his support of non-binary
people but adding sadly I've also been
harassed threatened doxed had my private
life speculated on and my loved ones
insulted and recognizing the feelings of
those who kindly raised their concerns
in a polite way I do not wish to
legitimize the great many people who use
their hurt as a cover for unacceptable
toxic and abusive behavior and here are
some responses to oli as a non-binary
fan of yours I'm disappointed in this
non apology again what exactly is he
supposed to be apologising for ever
having associated with me things we are
going to criticize oli philosophy too
poor being a sniveling hypocritical
piece of [ __ ] refusing to listen to
trans people actively openly and
repeatedly mocking the trans people he
refuses to listen to thanks for the
apology now stop and doors and contra
points now keep in mind that with these
Twitter people are doing is demand
that sis people publicly condemn a trans
woman for loosely associating with
another trans person does that strike
anyone else is wildly inappropriate even
me am older a trans woman who is never
publicly associated with me got attacked
because she tweeted a heart volley you
know after he made the post discussing
being dog stand threatened and just for
that she gets put on the enemy list I'm
sad to say that Mia is on the list of
people that have stood by contrapositive
piece of [ __ ] to which me responds stood
by contra points Jesus Christ no matter
what I do people call me out and I'm not
even related to the video and I don't
even know Natalie the chain of guilt by
association is so long and twisted I can
barely even follow it so they're going
after Mia
who tweeted a [ __ ] not oli who failed
to condemn me for my voice-over casting
of buck angel who was retweeted by a
Turk we're only missing a couple of
degrees of separation before every
living person on the planet Earth is
cancelled over the buck angels situation
and several colleagues of mine by the
way
Lindsey hariyali they all took a
financial hit over this they've all lost
some patreon support one of the
Lansing's former supporters even
demanded a $38 lifetime refund saying
dear Lindsey I'm sorry for being pushy
but I really am going to be needing a
refund I gave money to your operation
under the pretense that you wouldn't do
anything morally objectionable and
supporting contra points and blaming us
for taking issue with thought is in my
opinion a moral please respond I hope
she sent it to them in pennies so look
I'm very grateful to my colleagues for
sticking by me through all this but I'm
also aware that I'm becoming a burden to
anyone who associates with me I have no
collaborators in this video I'm working
on this totally alone because I'm aware
of how radioactive I am right now and I
don't want to contaminate anyone else
during the height of this most recent
cancelling a creator I admire deemed me
to let me know
I cut the shout-out to you in my last
video because I was nervous to draw the
ire of your detractors were getting
genuinely scary but I wouldn't want you
to think I was disavow you regardless of
how many people are asking me to Jesus
Christ the situation here is that any
citizen who defends me or even
associates with me in any way will be
labeled a transfer any binary trans
person who associates with me will be
branded an MP phobe and any non-binary
people who associate with me will be
ostracized from their own community so
in the Internet I find myself
increasingly alone I'm isolated by the
harassment and that is ultimately the
point and to exile me from my community
from any community and it's all because
I refuse to participate and doing
exactly that to bug angel my experiences
have made me so disillusioned with the
idea that social media call-outs can
lead to any kind of justice that have
essentially sworn off participating
amount there's a fairly prominent figure
and leftist politics who I could
absolutely hashtag me to but I'm never
gonna do it because I have no faith left
in the process of call out vigilante
justice and I'm not saying I'm totally
against me too
because I think in some cases it totally
is the brave and admirable thing to do
but in my case I feel like I just know
too much about the dark side of social
media shaming to ever want to
participate in it again you know I feel
like the story would end up being taken
out of my control warped and twisted in
all kinds of unpredictable ways that
would end up just haunting both me and
the person I'd be accusing which in this
case honestly neither of us deserves so
I'm just not willing to take that risk
except maybe in some very extreme
situation which this just isn't it's not
worth it and likewise when a mob is at
my doorstep demanding I condemn buck
angel to save myself from cancellation
no I'm just not gonna do that I'm a
conscientious objector I'm willing to go
to Twitter jail for this take me away
boys
[Music]
if there's one thing I can't stand it's
bread Tube videos part 8 now the
philosophy of being [ __ ] in the ass I
have done this to YouTube and I'm sorry
so look canceling is not criticism it is
not holding someone accountable it is an
attack on a human being in this video
are you Thord cancelling more or less
synonymously with what feminists show
freeman author of the [ __ ] manifesto
calls crashing and I've linked her essay
trashing the darkside of sisterhood and
the description it was originally
published in ms magazine in 1976 but it
is a perfect description of what goes on
on trans twitter today it is not
disagreement it is not conflict it is
not opposition these are perfectly
ordinary phenomena which when engaged in
mutually honestly and not excessively
are necessary to keep an organism or
organization healthy and active trashing
is a particularly vicious form of
character assassination which amounts to
psychological rape is manipulative
dishonest and excessive it is
occasionally disguised by the rhetoric
of honest conflict or covered up by
denying that any disapproval exists at
all but it is not done to expose
disagreements or resolve differences it
is done to disparage and destroy
whatever methods are used trashing
involves a violation of one's integrity
a declaration of one's worthlessness and
impugning of one's motives in effect
what is attacked is not one's actions or
one's ideas but one's self and that's
what distinguishes trashing bullying or
abuse from criticism or holding
accountable criticism attacks your
actions or beliefs but when people are
canceling me they're not bringing up my
problematic tweets because they want me
to revise my beliefs
No what they're doing is accumulating
evidence to support the case they've
decided to make that I am a horrible
person who must be shunned you know the
only sense in which I am
like to say the new Blair White is that
I think I actually have now snatched a
Vanessa's crown as the most hated Tran
on Tran Twitter Vanessa I've tried to
feud with you feud with me goddamnit you
can have a one-sided feud I don't want
to be one of those trans youtubers that
just drags other trans people all day
and they never respond that would be
really pathetic the new Laci green
that's the other one the newest in a
series of women you've decided to treat
like supervillains maybe reflect on that
habit a little bit hmm
and supervillain is the right word like
I'm the bad guy
duh I'm the enemy and what you do with
the enemy well you disavow disowned deep
platform and destroy as that one tweet
put it dots the line in the sand folks
where do you stand
if you adequately demonstrate your
searing hatred of Natalie win then
you're safe and cool but if you don't
you're on the wrong side of the line
sweaty and you two are now the enemy
Council culture troop 7 dualism certain
ancient religions teach their followers
to understand the cosmos as a struggle
between light and dark good and evil and
cancel culture does it more or less the
same thing it's binary thinking people
are either good or they're bad and to
add to that essentialism if a person
says or does a bad thing we should
interpret that as the mask slipping as a
momentary glimpse of their essential
wickedness and anyone who wants to
remain good had better be willing to
publicly condemn anyone the community
has decided is bad there really is
something dystopian about this you have
to be willing to accuse other people to
prove your own innocence that's the line
in the sand folks where do you stand and
the most extreme version of this all bad
people are equally bad so collaborating
with true scum means you may as well be
true scum and of course being true scum
is tantamount to being a turf and on
trans twitter it is a known fact that
turfs are Nazis and this implies that
Nazis turfs true scum people who
associate with true scum people who feel
to condemn people who associate with
true scum people who offer emotional
support to people who fail to condemn
people who associate with true scum all
of them must be treated the same way
deep platform her just like every other
racist sexist bigoted content creator a
fully wound backhand to the mouth I
recently read a book by Sarah Schulman
called conflict is not abuse overstating
harm community responsibility and the
duty of repair
basically Shulman's argument is that in
various contexts from romantic
relationships to community infighting to
international politics the overstatement
of harm is used as a justification for
cruelty and for escalating conflict so
for example and this is my example not
Shulman's turfs fixate on the
exaggerated danger that trans women
supposedly posed to assist women and in
very classic overstatement of harm
they'll describe everything they don't
like as a rape trans women entering
women's spaces is rape trans women
existing Janis Raymond is rape and then
they use that exaggerated harm as a
justification to retaliate against them
to Doc's and harass and shun well the
same kind of logic is used to justify
abusive behavior within the trans
community the dualistic thinking the
essentialism the pseudo moralism all of
this allows people on Twitter to treat
me in an obviously abusive way all the
while feeling like they're doing the
right thing because they're attacking
the enemy and I realize that some people
will say that I'm the one who's
overstating harm to evade criticism well
look you've seen the tweets the furious
demands for me to be exiled the daxing
and threatening and ordering a round of
my colleagues the attempts to isolate me
from a community the attacks not on my
actions but on Who I am as a person
there's not really anything ambiguous
about this it's just abuse but I don't
think it feels like abuse to the people
who are doing it they feel like they're
punching up because I must celebrity
with a platform and lots of twitter
followers and it's true that I do have
more power than any of them individually
but as a
elective they have a terrifying power
that they don't seem to be aware of as
individuals as John Watson author of a
great book on public shaming put it I
suppose that when shaming czar delivered
like remotely administers drone strikes
nobody needs to think about how
ferocious our collective power might be
the snowflake never needs to feel
responsible for the Avalanche and that's
how you get these situations where you
have hundreds of people endlessly
bashing someone who's already been
knocked to the ground and feeling all
the while like they're punching up you
know there's actually a kind of power
and safety in anonymity and obscurity
and there are many ways that being a
public figure makes you really
vulnerable for example you're more
vulnerable to daxing stalking and
harassment on a scale that most people
probably can't even imagine you're
vulnerable to having your reputation
permanently degraded in a way that
people who are posting anonymously or
pseudonymous lee are pretty much in
venerable - and a lot of the people who
are attacking me they're not pausing to
self-reflect
they're not holding themselves
accountable for the consequences of
their actions they're just venting their
unfiltered rage but in response to these
attacks I as a powerful person with a
platform I'm not allowed to react like a
human being I'm not allowed to get angry
I'm not allowed to show pain I'm not
allowed to get defensive I'm not allowed
to lash out all I'm allowed to do is go
totally nama the inside as I try to
frantically calculate the ideal public
relations response that pays due
deference to the valid concerns of these
poor marginalized people all the while
ignoring the tsunami of verbal abuse
that's crashing over me you know people
on Twitter they don't try to persuade me
like I'm a human being they order me
around they tell me what to believe they
demand that I say exactly what they want
me to say or else it's extremely
objectifying they don't treat me like a
person with my own opinions and feelings
they treat me as this like brand of
moral commodity to be consumed or
denounced and this is all terribly
ironic because of the conflicting demand
that creators be authentic all the time
one thing that always frustrates me
about these situations is there's this
demand that you apologize instantly and
there's this perception that a fast
apology is more sincere than a delayed
one but in fact the opposite is true it
takes longer than a couple hours to cool
down lower your defenses listen learn
grow seriously reflect on what you may
have done or said that was wrong that
can take days or weeks or months I had
to do my October am a stream for patreon
and at the beginning of the stream I
gave my emotional half formed reaction
to the buck angel situation and some
traitor on my patreon transcribed that
part of the stream and disseminated it
on Twitter just to instigate another
round of canceling you're not allowed a
chance to think or feel and because
supposedly the best thing to do from a
PR perspective is to apologize
immediately canceling produces a lot of
insincere [ __ ] apologies from people
who haven't in fact learned anything and
I think most people are aware of that in
fact I think the demand for an apology
itself is often insincere if you're
being canceled
rather than criticized the line in the
sand has been drawn you and all your kin
have been declared the enemy apologized
to Twitter at this point I may as well
apologize too for camp
dear 4chan I am super [ __ ] sorry I
called youth interested otaku
shitweasels who like looking at pictures
of little girls I have been trying to
educate myself and learn from my
mistakes and I now realize that's only
seventy percent of you like once you're
canceled you can really do no right if
you apologize the apology will be
declared a manipulative attempt to save
face and in fact it will be used as
further evidence of what a Machiavellian
psychopath you really are if you try to
explain or defend yourself I mean first
of all you almost certainly dig yourself
in deeper but even if you're articulate
and correct you'll still be seen as
unable to take criticize
and as ignoring the hurt of marginalized
people and if he just goes silent you'll
be seen as a coward fleeing
accountability even though there's lots
of reasons why you might go silent maybe
you're taking a few days away from
social media to try to cool down and
think clearly or maybe you're so
overwhelmed by the harassment that
you've just shut down let's do shots
wants to do a shot with me don't you to
shot with me let's do a shot tequila
shot is my favorite I like the whole
salt tequila-lime ritual it's just very
satisfying to me the end of that bottle
okay
just started you feel warm right away
you know feeling more it's like oh hey
how are you happiness hey how are you
feeling that life is worth to living
it's a good moment you're like oh this
isn't okay this is gonna be okay I can
get through this it's how it starts to
watch out for that so look I really
don't like to represent myself as a
victim that's not really a narrative
that I identify with but for the
purposes of communicating what effect
cancelling has I feel like I should say
something about the pain much of the
happiness that you might expect to come
along with success has been taken away
from me by this constant fury that
surrounds me try to think about this
rationally I'm a Libra Sun ycs Moon
being cancelled is hell for me you know
I want to be liked by everyone and I'm
starting to think I might be in the
wrong career for that in a way leftist
twitter finally accomplished with 4chan
Nazis stalkers and turf's
have been trying and failing to do to me
for years they've made Twitter into a
platform so hostile to my existence that
I've decided to leave it forever and
they demoralized me to the point I could
barely get out of bed for a month
and I know that sounds really
melodramatic but I'm just trying to be
honest with you about what a
melodramatic courtesan I am I find I
have trouble convincing people of the
severity of the pain that being
cancelled causes because I think it's
just hard to imagine if you haven't been
through it yourself and I don't know a
more succinct way to convey it to you
than by telling you that in the last few
years I've been harassed by Nazis I've
been harassed by turfs I've been stopped
I've been doxxed I've been threatened
I've been sexually assaulted and the
pain of being canceled of being totally
trashed by other trans people online for
years has been more difficult for me to
cope with than all the rest of it
combined Joe Freeman actually describes
how I feel better than I think I can
describe it myself
I was one of the first in the country
perhaps the first in Chicago to have my
character my commitment and my very self
at out in such a way by movement women
that have left me torn and little pieces
and unable to function it took me years
to recover and even today the wounds
have not entirely healed this attack is
accomplished by making you feel that
your very existence is inimical to the
movement and that nothing can change
this short of ceasing to exist these
feelings are reinforced when you are
isolated from your friends as they
become convinced that their association
with you is similarly animal to the
movement and to themselves any support
of you will taint them eventually all
your colleagues join in in a chorus of
condemnation which cannot be silenced
and you are reduced to a mere parody of
your previous self yeah that just about
sums it up now as it happens I am going
to survive this because I have very
deliberately built a support network
that will be there for me regardless of
what online trans communities say and I
have very deliberately done that because
early in my transition back in 2017 I
relied very heavily on the online
leftist trans community for all kinds of
emotional support you know when you're
early in transition I mean it just sucks
you feel like the whole world is against
you and I talk about this a little bit
in my last video you know feeling like a
freak show walking down the street and
even if you're lucky enough to have a
supportive family like
usually it still is gonna take them a
while to come around at first they don't
got it they say things to you like
aren't you worried you'll regret this
and like they struggle with your name
and pronouns which is understandable but
at the same time it makes you feel like
you're not being seen for who you are so
you need a kind of second family that
understands how you're feeling and acts
happy about your transition and
validates your gender and for the first
couple months of my transition I found
that in this world of online transgender
leftism well that didn't last long
because well I was what two months into
my transition when first I did an
interview with the journal is Jesse
single and then I agreed to do a debate
with Theron and Vanessa so that's a long
story but in short I associated with a
string of people that trans Twitter
considers the enemy and Trent's Twitter
tore me apart over this and it
completely broke my heart because I was
really leaning on basically emotional
support from strangers online seems
really stupid in retrospect and actually
turned against me I decided one that I
was never going to rely on this group of
people again and two that I was going to
have to find acceptance elsewhere and in
retrospect I think this actually may
have been good for me in a roundabout
way because I was kicked out of the safe
space and I dropped out mentality and so
basically I was thrown into the deep end
of reality and forced to sink or swim
and I don't know if my transition or my
channel would be where they are today if
it hadn't been for that trial by fire
I'll be swimming through fire or are we
mixing metaphors
the point is I'm more armored against
cancelling than I was two years ago and
the reason why is I have acquired a
certain level of privilege and security
and independence from any one community
so that if one community cancels me I
still have somewhere else to go you know
the people who are most vulnerable to
cancel culture are not white guy
comedians they're not James Charles
they're not me they are marginalized
people who feel like they have nowhere
else to go when they're rejected by
their community that means struggling
trans people with a few hundred Twitter
followers it means a lot of sex workers
it means people who totally rely on
activist circles for emotional and
material support I'll quote Roe Freeman
one more time
I had survived my youth because I had
never given anyone or any group the
right to judge me that right
I had reserved to myself but the
movement seduced me by its sweet
promises sisterhood it claimed to
provide a haven from the ravages of a
sexist society a place where one would
be understood it was my very need for
feminism and feminists that made me
vulnerable I gave the movement the right
to judge me because I trusted it and
when it judged me worthless I accepted
that judgment there's a really
irritating point that people on the Left
like to make that goes well cancelling
doesn't really end anyone's career
cancelled people usually get a new job
or keep their platform so I guess it's
not really that bad huh
I think people say this because they're
trying to mitigate any sense of guilt
they might feel about how they're
treating people because it's a really
stupid argument there's lots of things
that don't end your life they're still
terrible but also there's cases where
cancelling has ended someone's life on
December 5th 2017 a porn star named -
August Eames killed herself by hanging
in a public park after being cancelled
on Twitter over a homophobic tweet on
December 3rd she tweeted whichever lady
performer is replacing me tomorrow for
erotica acts News you're shooting with a
guy who was shot gay porn just to let
you know BS is all I can say
shrug do agents really not care about
who they're representing la Direct I do
my homework for my body so I've never
worked in porn so I can't really tell
you what the norms are around women
working with men who have done gay porn
but the tweet
certainly sounds homophobic to me and
that seems to be the consensus of other
industry people on Twitter so Twitter
did his thing people in August's
community called her a homophobe and
lashed out at her and as always happens
plenty of passers-by jumped in to throw
tomatoes at the woman in the stocks over
the next few days August tweeted several
more times going through the usual
stages that you go through when you're
being canceled first she defended
herself she claimed most other women in
the industry feel the same as her then
she said she's bisexual and therefore
she couldn't be homophobic then she said
fine I'll guess I'll be fake and I have
opinions then then she started by
moaning how mean twitter is and she got
really defended
about her right to choose who she sucks
with and she latched out of the people
attacking her and then in her final
tweet she just said [ __ ] y'all and went
to the park that night and killed
herself this is all so familiar to me I
feel like I'm able to relive with her
each stage of this emotional process
there's that first moment when you
realize the outrage is beginning and you
get that sinking feeling in your stomach
and an anger feeling misunderstood and
then the bargaining the fear and finally
the shame and the despair and here's the
thing I totally agree with her critics
that her tweet was bad of course she has
the right to say no for any reason but
she publicly expressed this in a
homophobic way but she was still a
person who deserves to live and I think
there's got to be a better way to deal
with these situations than just trashing
someone until they kill themselves and I
know it's never as simple as Twitter
made her kill herself there's always
other things going on in the background
but the point I'm making is cancelling
is more dangerous to marginalized people
because marginalized people generally
have more things going on in the
background John Watson did an
investigative podcast about her death
and it goes into how she was sexually
abused as a child abandoned by her
father she was living with a boyfriend
she was kind of emotionally detached
from it a few weeks earlier she'd filmed
a scene with a guy who was unnecessarily
rough and mean and who mistreated her so
she was kind of traumatized by that and
so she was kind of on edge and really
defensive about who she worked with when
she was tweeting that the backlash
happened and since she had no other
support network she probably felt like
the only community she had turned
against her and that's a really painful
feeling she must have felt so despised
which is how I have felt for the last
two months I feel despised and
burdensome and I can imagine how a
person who feels that way could have an
impulsive couple hours where they think
their best option is suicide I mean I
can more than imagine it because I've
been there myself and I'm still here
because at those moments I've been with
good friends who took care of me and by
friends I do mean xanax
but I've also survived because there's a
lot of people on the internet who me
very entertained if I killed myself and
I simply refused to give them the
satisfaction oh no [ __ ] find chess to
live as long as far as what of sheer
spite
I mean who needs a guardian angel when
you can make it through Christmas after
Christmas on the fumes of total contempt
what I'm really trying to say is Merry
Christmas you god damn [ __ ]
Oh Holy Night the stars are brightly
shining yeah yeah yeah no yeah yeah yeah
no yeah to get my lesbian Flyers out
again
I was super [ __ ] happy new-year
words how am I gonna get this bathtub
out of my apartment
anyone in Baltimore want a bathtub leave
a comment if you want a bathtub alright
I need to take a deep breath because
let's be honest I've got one crack away
from attacking my own Twitter followers
with an umbrella I had about one
breakdown away from going on a rampage
and making a suit out of women's skin
just kidding I would never do that
there on a bad skin day I've given it
serious consideration oh I'll be fine
I've gotta sober up anyway because I'm
having more plastic surgery in a couple
days and plastic surgery that's about
the only thing holding me together at
this point
oh you tubing that this is a healthy
profession this is great anyone want my
job stop right up all you have to do is
make informative and entertaining videos
about extremely controversial topics Wow
of course representing the full range of
experiences in the lgbtqia+ spectrum and
being perfectly woke and irreverent ly
funny well go on I'm waiting to be
entertained feed me mother oh don't mind
me y'all just sit back pour another
glass of wine oh and I will of course be
obsessively scrutinizing every word you
say for any hint of moral transgression
as well as critiquing your look a
third-rate crossdresser zero out of ten
get off my stage he's like that's
believed to build that everywhere good I
just don't want to talk about why people
cancel and the effect that is having but
it looks like there's gonna have to be a
part to gorge because I have hit my
limit
so why don't we all cut our losses and
try again in 2020 mmmm I realize that
people on Twitter are actually gonna
watch this video they're just gonna make
fun of the title and how long it is
which fair enough but they're the ones
whose accusations against me are so
numerous and convoluted it required a
feature-length film to respond to the
other gonna see the title and they're
gonna transcribe quotes out of context
and they're gonna say I'm a fascist I'm
a turf I'm true scum I'm the new Blair
white I'm the new Laci green my missus
but liquor
I'm an enlightened centrist I'm a [ __ ]
Lib I'm alright I'm a heartless grifter
raking in millions of dollars over the
bodies of dead trans women mask off
yikes this ain't it chief friendly
reminder that this isn't a good look
maybe don't be a [ __ ] licker
disappointing but they're saying all
those things already so I'm inoculated
see their mistake was completely
breaking my spirit they should have left
a little peace and talked but it's good
it's good it's good because basically my
survival from here on out hinges on my
ability to not care at all what people
say about me online so here's to not
giving a [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is almost a Norma Desmond cosplay
which is good because I'm not gonna age
gracefully and it's the best to get into
character now YouTube stars never die